to be a part of something that people
really appreciate as much as maybe
certain people hate to admit it and it's
important to us like it's always for me
it's always been like some more simple
things in life that I've appreciated and
to be honest with us you're like too
much focus and I feel like too much
attention with the employees from things
that really are no relevance for me it
was really just an idea and as a single
person
what's an idea doesn't really mean
anything what makes it live and breathe
the people that subscribe to the
philosophy and the idea of it
he was an American actor who began his
television career guest starring in
shows like touched by an angel and a
young and the restless' he rose to
international fame for playing Brian
O'Conner in the hit series fast in the
Furious he also founded the charity
reach out worldwide which was an
organization that helped provide relief
efforts to countries when they had
natural disasters he's Paul Walker and
here is my take on his top ten rules of
success rule number two is our personal
favorite I make sure to stick around all
the way to the end with some special
bonus clips also as Paul was talking if
you said something that really resonates
with you please leave it in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
Oh
I woke up every morning excited I was
completely jacked I've never been more
excited to go to work every day as I was
on this project at the end of the day
I've never been more drained in my life
but somehow someway I found the energy
every morning to get up and just go for
it and the further we got into it the
more lewane was just like okay do what
you want to do what you want to do and I
never had that kind of freedom before I
enjoy doing them but more than that
actually let me rephrase it I think the
reason why I enjoy it so much is because
how much the people get off the audience
appreciates what we do you know there's
a lot of things I could be doing outside
of the industry even within the industry
but you know I don't know if the
satisfaction would be the same and I'll
be kids to be a part of something that
people really appreciate as much as
maybe certain people hate to admit it
and it's important to us you know as
humans it's like you want to believe
that you know what you're putting out
there and what you've dedicated so much
time to is there's a certain degree of
acknowledgment and more than
acknowledgement and appreciation you
know obviously this one has been
appreciated for a long time and it's
that's a great feeling
there really isn't a whole lot of
pressure stress making a movie like this
I mean I think the most pressure is
probably felt by the stunt men when they
got to go do some crazy stunts because
now they're putting their life on the
line you know there's never a guarantee
there's always a degree of risk but for
me you know it's more just about showing
up and having a good time and you know
doing the best that I can do but I could
really only worry about myself you know
and to me it's you know if it doesn't
feel right it's probably not right so
let's figure out we can fix it let's uh
I didn't roll with it you know one day
at a time for me the way I live my life
that's the way I do my job you know just
come in and just I try to do my best I
give it 110% oh when you first signed up
for the first one which is back in like
99 2000 and did you think you'd be
sitting here in 2013 talking about
number six no no chance no screenplay
nothing when I find
as just an idea that's funny because I
wanted to do it you know working with my
friends I'd already worked with these
people before and now I you can't do it
my representative told me you can't do
it so scared there's nothing and then
you didn't listen to their advice all
right I got lucky but I just you know
following your heart kind of thing and
it wasn't even about down the road it
was about living in the moment got lucky
Nona to be miss to be somebody who is
available and in the sense I'm very
quiet yes certainly going to the house
to get something that we don't know that
well I think I think it serves just kind
of preservation of the whole thing
because like I've always considered
myself to be Jenna I don't I don't
subscribe to what's put in our say I
could go as for me it's always been like
the Martian okay unless that I've
appreciated and to be honest with you I
feel like too much focus and I feel like
too much attention with the input some
things that really are no relevance and
just really aren't important and you
know from a crazy reality shows and all
that stuff that we have right here so
you know what I'm talking about
and so it's like if if you're playing in
that world alright and you're sensitive
to not wanting to play into it to that
degree
there's always trepidation and every
step admit because you don't want to be
misinterpreted or misunderstood people
are so afraid to offend or say something
you know it's like you know maybe if I
say this you know I had jeopardized you
know my career maybe I won't get another
job you know I don't want to bad-mouth
this person or that person first thing I
like to be straight up you know and if I
if I had some smack you know on or some
you know some trash to talk about
someone I'd be comforted to give it to
you right now for me it's really based
on my reaction is based on the general
public's reaction
now I don't know if I like something
until I know the people like it you know
especially in movies like this where the
people that the fans are very passionate
about it and you know the first one was
well-received the second one is really
flowy feed and now here we are making a
fourth one I don't want to disappoint
you know there's a lot of fans out there
so if they're happy I'm happy that's
pretty much what it comes down to how is
the relationship when you're not
shooting are you guys like friends and I
mean you've been a we're friends like
you know there's times where people
driving nuts you know they like it in
real life
yeah in real life you know it just it
happens I mean we've been working
together for so long and there's certain
personalities are mine really you still
like that guy but you know you just you
just learn to accept people for who they
are and what it's about I mean you know
there's been a lot of self-discovery for
all of us on this too you know I just I
love Tyrese like a brother he drives me
insane sometimes you know and we give
each other a hard time you know but
there's always love between us you know
then we come from opposite coasts and we
got two completely different approaches
to life imagine that you know this
childhood was completely different than
month so sometimes we don't only see eye
to eye but I think we complement one
another
I understand love quite involved with
your foundation where you are doing some
great things for people and and other
people could value to you with you know
getting something about how come we
didn't know anything about that I just
found that like they found it
about what who's trying to do that it's
just not about advertising it's about
just doing right the thing that I like
is it's not it's this isn't this isn't a
promotional campaign this is something
worth it was just an idea and a few
firms worth the hate that's all it was
and then a teacher named aquila and then
she lay turned into Pig Indonesia and
then that turned into more recently the
tornado thing and then was along the way
that we realized that we had something
that was good that will actually carry
no more taking interest rates so the
idea became a foundation it wasn't like
this is the ideal is to be a foundation
it was just like minded friends but it's
a small group of eight to twelve people
we go in we can make it happen within 42
to 72 hours and by the time the Red
Cross comes around we can be like this
is what we figured out and now with then
I I wanted to remain small and intimate
like that it's important I never want to
nobody wants that this involved what's
the dicamba speaker because we learn or
be effective yeah you like it right and
you know it's like we're not going to
move mountains like they would drop them
but it's like we're like that little
pebble in the park you notice that we
really believe it's like if you can
impact one person's life one family's
life that radiates that and so that's
just a lot of us what we're trying to
stick with yeah with Road things reach
out worldwide things have moved along
really well I mean its inception was
last year last year long we had three or
four outings we had one this year we had
the tornado on Tuscaloosa and Alabama
but this year for the most part has been
relatively sleepy which has been nice
but what's happened is there's been a
bit of a groundswell and organically
what's happened is we've had different
brands express interest and potentially
sponsoring us or helping us with our
cause so the thing that's nice is we put
something out there that we believed in
and and others have jumped on dab it off
for instance with their you know their
donation and
and since then still they make a
chainsaws and a lot of our tools and we
use a lot of their equipment in
extraction especially in tuscaloosa it
can cut in trees to you know remove
debris and how people gain access to
their home and it's just it's exciting
it's exciting to see what's happening so
the thing that I like is you know so
long as I'm alive and kick'n and I'm
making money and things are going well
you know ro can continue but there's
going to come with time or I might not
necessarily be able to fund it and so
you know to know that there's you know
the outside interests that are coming in
now to know that there's a good chance
that this is something they could
potentially be around
well after I leave this planet it's a
it's a good feeling and and the
like-minded I think the people that
believe in it because for me it was
really just an idea and as a single
person
what's an idea doesn't really mean
anything what makes it live and breathe
the people that subscribe to the
philosophy and the idea of it and the
people that are involved and just taking
it to a completely different level so
I'm really fortunate and the people that
are involved are just really good people
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Neum te I hope I
pronounced that okay asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
are gonna profile next leave it down the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know what did Paul
say that has the biggest impact on you
what are you going to take home from
this video that you're going to
immediately apply to your life or your
business leave it in the comments and
I'm going to join in the discussion and
finally I want to give a quick shout-out
to kamo today oh thank you so much for
buying a copy of my book your one word
and taking that awesome picture with it
outside the Eiffel Tower in Paris it
really really really means a lot to me
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much loved I'll see you soon
very few of us you know myself included
in the few you know on the early trips
or really I was really one of the only
ones it didn't have any professional
experience and I realized that my skill
set was limited so I didn't like that
feeling as much as I picked up while we
were there and in the field I realized
that there was more to learn and that's
a big part of it that really keeps me I
think drawn is like you know we're only
here one time and I love the arena I
love learning about first aid you know
anything pertaining to medicine it's
just it's fascinating to me so it's one
thing I continue to work on and work
toward some work forward with and you
know hopefully within not too much
longer I'll feel qualified super
qualified who's the most badass guy on
set who the most the waves the biggest
guy yeah he's pretty athletic um I can
do the most I can surf and I can skate
and I can play volleyball and do all
that stuff those guys can't do that so
it's all a matter of how you you know
what you learn what you value I guess I
race cars I can drive better than
everybody else then
everybody's looking for you in the
trailer man I just called your phone
like what are you doing man dog what are
you doing I'm Vin Diesel oh look if you
see you like this doggies re gonna flip
out are you doing too much right now
these are time these are done deal
it needs that ha ha ha Ezreal inta
teaches back in 2002 it was you the MTV
audience that first acknowledged this
Brotherhood between Paul Walker myself
by honoring us with the best team on
film so it's surreal to be standing here
12 years later and that you have been so
generous to give us this award again
I wish you could be here to see this but
I know he's here in Stuart thank you for
honoring me and more importantly thank
you for honoring that angel my brother
Paul Walker